Right.
Let's get going or we'll be late for school.
Why do I have to go to school?
There are lots of reasons why we have to go to school.
The main reason for going to school is to learn new things.
Like I learned how to count to 20 yesterday?
Yes!
Or how to read,...
...how to write,...
...play music,...
...to use the computer.
I learned a new dance in school and a new song.
What else do you do in school?
I play with my friends.
So school also helps you to meet new friends and play with them.
Sometimes I share my crayons with Julie and she shares her markers with me.
So school gives us a chance to share things together.
Sometimes I work on a picture by myself...
...and sometimes I work hard with my friends to make things.
So in school we learn how to work together with our friends and how to work on our own.
Sometimes we have teams and I have to wait till it's my turn to run.
I get very excited when I'm doing sports.
It's important to exercise.
And school helps us to exercise in a fun way.
Do you know what else I like doing in school?
What's that?
Next week I'm going to be in a concert...
...and I'm going to be the wolf and you can come watch me, yeah!
I'd love to.
And then you can come and watch me on my sports day, running and jumping.
So there's lots of things I can do in school with my friends...
...that I might not be able to do at home on my own.
That's true.
It's great to come home from school,...
...to have your dinner and to play and talk and have a rest!
Yes.
And it's also great to go into school and meet your teachers and your friends.
And all the new things you can learn,...
...like answers to some of these questions you keep asking me!